what we're going to talk about in this
video is voter turnout which is a way of
thinking about well how many of the
people who could vote actually do vote
if it's often expressed as a number as a
percentage where you have the number
who vote
number who vote
over the number of eligible voters
number
who
could vote
who could vote
and this percentage varies pretty
dramatically from region to region
amongst various demographic groups we'll
talk about that in a few minutes and
especially if you think about even
sometimes year to year and from country
to country there's some countries that
have mandatory voting where this number
is a lot higher other countries for what
various reasons this number could be a
lot lower and one thing for you to think
about if you're already a voting age you
might have already thought this or if
you're not voting yet you will soon
what would drive you to vote or what
would drive you to not vote stay home or
somehow keep you from engaging in this
political process
well one thing that you'll often hear
folks say is does my vote matter
does
my
vote matter
and the typical response that you would
get if you say that is well if everyone
thought that well then the democracy
really won't function so yes your vote
does matter so that's the high level way
of thinking about it but everyone thinks
about this to a certain degree and this
idea of thinking about whether your vote
matters a fancy way of describing that
is you're thinking about your political
efficacy
political
efficacy fancy political science term
but it's really just this idea of
what's my belief about how politically
effective i can be when i vote
if i am in a battleground state say
florida where even presidential
elections have turned on a few hundreds
of votes in florida you might say hey i
have high political efficacy my vote
does matter there but some folks who
live in a state that might be strongly
leaning towards one party or another
during a presidential election say a
california that tends to go to a
democrat or say a texas that tends to go
to republican
regardless of which party you are you
say well if i'm just one more republican
vote in texas does my vote matter if i'm
one more democratic vote in california
does my vote matter i would encourage
you in both cases your vote does matter
if everyone believes that then then our
democracy does not function now a
related idea to political efficacy is
this idea of well just how engaged
are people so i'll call that engagement
and this might be well how much do they
care so beyond does my vote matter
there is a notion of do i care
there are certain elections where you
might really like one candidate or might
really dislike another candidate you
might think hey there's some big issues
on the table that really affect my life
so i might be more engaged or frankly
the various candidates or the various
political parties or community
organizations might just be better at
engaging the population now a third
dimension beyond whether people believe
their vote matters or how engaged they
are in the issues or the candidates is
the structure around voting itself what
state laws are there around voting and
how easy or how hard is it to vote so
for example if there's a big window of
time where people can vote and if the
polling places are really accessible
especially if they're available on say a
holiday then it might be easier for
people to actually go to vote but on the
other hand if they aren't that
accessible or if it's on a day where a
lot of folks might need to work or
certain demographics might need to work
well they might be less likely to turn
out you also have laws around absentee
ballots or people being able to vote
ahead of time the easier it is
logistically to vote the more accessible
it is you're going to get a higher
turnout now political scientists don't
just study voter turnout to understand
the past they look at the past to try to
make predictions about the future at the
next congressional election the next
presidential election as they're trying
to figure out which way it might go
you can't just survey people alone and
say well
are you going to vote for this candidate
or that candidate because you also have
to think about how likely are they to
vote and that likelihood could be based
on various factors it might be based on
their age it might be based on their
race it might be based on their
education level and to appreciate that
let's start taking a look at some data
this chart right over here shows voter
turnout by sex and age in the 2008 u.s
presidential election where the blue
bars are males and the red bars are
females and then you could see that in
the different age groups and so pause
this video it's just fun to look at
these things what what takeaways are
there here
well you can see that if you're if you
look at all of the eligible voters total
18 years and over that women had a
higher voter turnout than men 60.4
percent of eligible women voted only
55.7 percent of men think about why that
might be what beliefs might women have
around
their own political efficacy relative to
men maybe they're more engaged maybe
there's issues on the table that they
care more about
and then if you look by age group that
trans tends to be true it's most
pronounced at the younger age groups but
then things get more and more equal as
we go to the older age groups the only
place where that trend breaks down is in
75 years and over and then you also have
the general trend that older folks are
more likely to vote once again why is
that
here's another interesting chart this is
voter turnout by educational attainment
for the same u.s presidential election
2008. so you can see that on average
across all education levels you have
this voter turnout around 58.2
but the more educated people get the
more they're likely or at least in that
election the more likely they were to
actually vote the more educated people
are they might feel more engaged they
might have a better belief that their
vote is effective so they have a belief
around political efficacy
this is voter turnout in the 2008
u.s presidential election by race and
ethnicity
and so here you see that in that
election white voters had 64.8 percent
turnout black voters 60.8 percent and
you can see asian and hispanic voters
were much much lower what does this say
about political engagement and what does
it say about their beliefs around
political efficacy
and to see trends over time i'm going to
go to the site of fairvote.org
which is a really great non-partisan
nonprofit that is trying to think about
how do we get a better democracy
so this diagram right over here shows
voter turnout rates from 1916 to 2016.
and there's two different lines here the
top one is in presidential elections
this is the 2016 presidential election
and this bottom line right over here is
in midterm elections so this is where
there isn't someone running for
president why do you think that there's
such a big gap here that pretty
consistently you have a much higher
voter turnout in this depending on what
year you look at but say in 2016 you
have a 60 voter turnout while in the
midterm election of 2014 you didn't even
break 40 percent you had a little under
36 voter turnout why do you think you
have this big gap
well you could probably turn to these
ideas of political efficacy and
engagement one thing that people talk
about around congressional seats is that
there tends to not be a lot of turnover
around it we've in other videos we've
talked about how the districts might be
shaped to benefit incumbents that the
entire process might be benefiting
incumbents so people might say hey i
have a very low political efficacy here
most congress people tend to stay in
office so maybe that's why they don't
really
go out to vote and there might be an
engagement thing going on that on
presidential years where also congress
people are up for re-election or up for
election the reason why people go out to
vote is presidential elections are these
really big dramatic things they take
over the press they take over everyone's
attention now another interesting thing
to think about is the trend why say in
presidential elections actually in
presidential and midterm elections do
you have such high engagement in the
1960s
relative to say the 1980s and 1990s
where things got pretty low one argument
could be that the 1960s was a time of
very high political engagement you had
the vietnam war going on you had the
civil rights movement now if we scroll
down on fair vote right over here we can
see voter turnout in the 2016 elections
by state
and the deeper the purple here the
higher the turnout and so what patterns
do ha do you see here and i'll give you
a hint think about which states are
battleground states the ones that could
flip either way in or the ones that
could have flipped either way in the
2016 election
well you could see the deeper purple are
in states like florida or in states like
ohio or
wisconsin and it's indeed in michigan
these indeed are battleground states so
you can imagine folks in those states
believed that they had higher political
efficacy
now in the 2014 elections you don't see
it as dramatic this is a mid-term
election year so people are thinking a
lot less about the electoral college and
presidential elections so it isn't as
all or nothing as they are in the
electoral college in the presidential
elections and so you don't see it as
pronounced but if you go back to 2012
which was a presidential election year
you see the same pattern again that the
battleground states are a deeper color
so i will leave you there you should
vote that's just my public service
message but it's interesting to think
about why in general voter turnout might
change